have you ever heard of Zhi Ling Ezeli
you know what I'm talking about the two
main protagonists of the beloved Legend
of Zelda franchise link and oh yeah
Zelda and about how sometimes it's super
almost totally confirmed but they're a
couple and sometimes people are like now
they're siblings which is not okay by
the way well in either of those
circumstances if Link and Zelda are
related in any way wouldn't that mean
that link is you know a member of the
Hylian royal family we're gonna dive
right into Zelda lore to check this
stuff out but first a message for some
very special people if you'd like to
skip the message and get straight to the
juicy stuff feel free to skip ahead to
the timestamp displayed on the screen go
ahead I'll meet you there hey guys it's
me you know Maspeth endo bandit
it is way too late to be recording this
but you know what I don't care I
probably look terrible right now
unshaven super sleepy stuff like that
didn't even care to do my hair or
anything like that which is why I'm
wearing this but you know what whatever
I'm gonna get straight to this I just
wanted to take a second and talk to you
that's right you there watching this I
just wanted to say happy 200 something
subscribers or whatever it is that we're
at right now I just wanted to take a
little bit of time and say something
because this is actually a really
important milestone for me now I know
that we live in a day and age we're
seeing numbers like a million or a
hundred thousand behind the subscribe
account of a channel is pretty common
you know and generally pretty expected
of like an up-and-coming
and trust me I am well aware of the size
of my own channel but that aside I just
wanted to say do I even know 200 people
I mean 200 people it's kind of a lot I
don't even think I can fit 200 people in
my apartment or even like two apartments
it is so humbling to think that there
are 200 somewhat people out there who
I'm probably never going to meet in
person I mean maybe I've probably never
met them but there are 200 something
people out there that saw this nobody on
YouTube who just likes to make a weird
video every now and then and thought hey
you know what I'm gonna let that guy
know that I wouldn't hear what he has to
say I think he's funny or I think he's
smart or I think he's whatever whatever
your reason was for subscribing you saw
me and you decided to support me all I
have to say about that is thank you to
every subscriber thank you honestly
whenever I get a new subscriber like
legit I can't stop smiling for hours
after that it literally makes my day you
guys are the best kind of people also to
all of you who are completely new here
or this is the first time you're seeing
me the first time you were watching
thank you you are also the best kind of
person because you're interested in what
I have to say and you're still here
dang I hope you consider sticking around
after seeing what I got anyway I've
rambled on for long enough but one less
time a huge thank you
new and old subscriber or not thank you
for being here and now onto the content
[Music]
so let's start with disproving what
would appear to be the converse of
romance between them this has over the
years been the cause for a lot of
theories about their relationship
actually being brother and sister maybe
even cousin I mean hey they are both
blond-haired blue-eyed and around the
same age right so why not be related
this is obvious sarcasm in the game a
Link to the Past basically the absolute
first thing you do is wake up and I mean
go figure our boy link here is like
always sleeping at the start of the game
no seriously he is have
game anyway you wake up you exit your
house and you look for your uncle you
find your uncle after a couple minutes
of searching and he's unfortunately
fatally wounded you do however get to
hear his dying words which are and I
quote mm-hmm save the princess
Zelda is did you guys like that voice
yeah should totally be a voice actor
what could it mean could it be that he
meant to say Zelda is your sister nope
now this is absolutely up for some
debate but we actually have some
evidence to the contrary you see in the
Game Boy Advance version of the game
this same text has been retranslated
your uncle no longer says Zelda is your
dot-dot-dot he instead says this and I
quote you must rescue Princess Zelda
hello people dup fated to do so period
my conclusion from these two different
translations of the same piece of
dialogue is that delving into some Zelda
lore real quick links uncle meant to say
something along the lines of Zelda being
links sworn duty to protect let me
explain have you ever heard of the
Knights of Hyrule aka
the highly at Knights now this clan of
elite Knights is not to be confused with
a regular hyrulean soldier let's take a
quick history lesson shall we the
Knights of Hyrule were an elite clan of
warriors test by the king of Hyrule
fight back against Ganon and his armies
during the imprisoning war the Knights
carry on generation after generation
through descendants of their bloodlines
of which links uncle and by extension
link himself are a part this is why
links uncle knew the super secret spin
attack technique which has been
confirmed to be a unique sort Eknath
known only by the Knights of Hyrule the
Knights are warriors sworn to serve
Hylian royalty on the night of the
events of a Link to the Past take place
Link's uncle was going out to protect
the princess because Ganon's forces were
at hand when he died he entrusted link
with the nightly duties of protecting
the princess at all costs and sealed it
with the secret sword tech
so yeah link is basically a knight to
Zelda not a sibling
okay so Lincoln Zelda boom not siblings
so is ceilings that cannon calm down
calm down I'm getting there I will say
that unfortunately they've never been
confirmed 100% to be a couple but there
is one game in particular that seems to
really really really imply they are over
all the others and if they are well that
could change everything in the game
Skyward Sword which is the
chronologically first Zelda game in the
franchise which features the foraging of
the fabled Master Sword itself Link and
Zelda are heavily implied to have
feelings for each other I mean just
watch this
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
no way oh my god
[Music]
hyoni
[Music]
how is that not just the cutest and most
terrifying think you've ever seen anyway
at the end of the game here be spoils by
the way Link and Zelda both choose to
stay on the surface world alone there
aren't any other humans we know of that
lived down there so you know what that
means
repopulation and you know what that
means what that means babies and you
know what that means what that means
what that okay it is implied that
ceiling though happens I mean what else
makes sense the pieces are there for
their feelings towards one another the
setting seems right I mean they even let
their loft wings go so they can't even
fly away from each other if they wanted
to so let's say that they did get
together what does this mean for the
heroes bloodline I mean wouldn't it mean
that since all Zelda's are descendant of
the original Zelda all links are
descended from the original link no
actually no so this may or may not come
as a surprise to you but it has never
ever been stated anywhere that link is
always a descendant of a previous link
just sometimes like for instance in
Twilight Princess we come across the
hero shade which has been confirmed to
be linked from Ocarina of Time also
known as the hero of time the shade
refers directly to the hero of Twilight
as his descendant aka his bloodline now
we have no way of telling whether or not
the hero of time got with the Zelda from
the original child timeline in Ocarina
of Time however if we were to assume
that the term spirit of the hero
actually means bloodline of the hero
since the hero shade seems to imply they
are one on the same then this would
absolutely mean that all links are
related to one another across
generations except for the Wind Waker
link and onward sorry buddy this would
mean that drum roll please the links are
related to the original link who were
pretty positive shacked up with the
original Zelda and are therefore all
sharing the Hylian royal blood making
link a pretty now unfortunately this is
all just a theory because we have no
confirmation that the links are all
related but
I don't know there could be something I
missed somewhere that says differently
hey if you're watching this you are more
than welcome to correct me also it's
that time thank you so much for watching
please consider growing the channel and
subscribing to stick around maybe drop a
like and comment below what you thought
of this theory anyway as always I hope
you have a fantastic rest of your day
peace
[Music]